when FTX went down it took a lot of
Esports money with it but now it might
do something else too it might change
the way we think about how streamers and
YouTubers endorse products online and it
could have implications for Esports more
generally that's because there's a new
one billion dollar class action lawsuit
aimed directly at the influencers who
were paid to promote FTX online let's
take a look
okay so if you use the internet you've
probably heard of the collapse of FTX
one of the largest crypto exchanges in
the world the collapse in November had
immediate impact because FTX was burning
a lot of money to advertise itself
basically everywhere including Esports
we're talking massive multi-year
multi-million dollar deals with some of
the biggest players in the space I'll
come back to that in a bit but it's
important because of esports's well
recent troubles anyways one thing that
FTX spent a lot of money on was
influencer advertisements specifically
Financial advice influencers and now a
new lawsuit alleges that these
influencer promotions were a big part of
how FTX was able to grow so big so
quickly the suit filed in the southern
district of Florida targets a number of
social media influencers and YouTubers
who were paid to promote FTX and their
yield bearing accounts long story very
short these were basically a accounts
that FTX offered where you could deposit
your cryptocurrency in and earn like a
yearly yield these yields were pretty
competitive compared to other Financial
options that you might have had some
would say maybe you know too lucrative
and when FTX disappeared well so did the
crypto so the lawsuit basically says
that these YouTubers some of whom have
millions of subscribers by the way
should be held liable for either one
failing to disclose the situation that
FTX accurately or two for basically
having this reason to be biased also
known as being paid and not disclosing
the exact amount of that reason the
lawsuit also points out that these
standards are justifiable because as
early as 2017 the U.S Securities and
Exchange Commission was warning that
these kinds of products might very well
be considered Securities a specific kind
of financial instrument if they were
certain rules and standards would apply
under the law like they would need to be
registered and if you were promoting one
you would need to disclose how much you
got paid anyways that's enough financial
garbage for now the question of whether
this lawsuit can succeed though is open
because it's not clear that these
influencers would qualify as an agent or
employee in the relevant section of
Florida law so the primary plaintiff of
this suit is the same as another high
profile FTX case which is filed against
the celebrities that promoted it
including people like Tom Brady and
Larry David side note I read that Shaq
is like holed up in his house to avoid
getting served that lawsuit or something
and man I just want to say it's not
actually Chris Paul trying to get you
hello police Chris Paul's trying to beat
me up okay enough joking around though
what does this mean for Esports well
frankly it doesn't seem likely that this
lawsuit or one like it would expand to
Esports Riot games definitely promoted
FTX because they had a deal to do so and
so did TSM but they're not exactly
Financial advice influencers and it's
going to be hard to link either of them
to a discussion of yield bearing
accounts I guess and again it's not
clear that either of these legal cases
will actually move forward a judge could
decide that the celebrities and
influencers just don't meet the
definition of agent or employee under
this Florida law and that's kind of One
Direction that some of the accused have
taken so far in a discussion with coffee
Zilla who has a far more in-depth video
on the lawsuit specifically if you want
to go that direction Kevin pafrath who
runs the YouTube channel meet Kevin
argued that his messaging around crypto
was clear regardless of the sponsorship
there needs to be a better there needs
to be a lot more diligence in when
sponsorships are made uh with creators
yeah because you guys are dealing with
finances this isn't like this isn't a
nordvpn ad where things go wrong you
know something happens this is like if
something goes wrong people's entire
Lively goods are at stake and For Better
or For Worse you guys are seen as uh the
experts and so you guys are held to that
expert standard individually I've always
said look crypto is extremely
speculative and that it should represent
a tiny portion of your portfolio if
anything at all on top of that it's also
incumbent upon the individual to take
some responsibility that we know not
your keys not your crypto that's been
made abundantly clear that's probably
enough about crypto because at least in
my opinion I don't think ride is going
to be facing a lawsuit over the FTX gold
differential or whatever anytime soon so
we're left with the most obvious kind of
damage the massive withdrawal of money
from the Esports space we've generally
seen many teams cutting back as the year
continues and it feels like that's
probably going to be a trend at the same
time it presents opportunities for other
entities with money for example Saudi
Arabia to spend these on tournaments as
Esports tries desperately to monetize
itself it remains a Haven for these
kinds of
non-traditional and some might say ugly
investment take for example The Gamers 8
CS go tournament an event set to take
place this August that boasts a one
million dollar prize pool just a bit
less than the last valve major I think
this phenomenon sometimes called Sports
washing or in our case Esports washing I
guess merits of video all on its own but
you can see how openings like this can
be created especially of prize pools
elsewhere in Esports remain where they
are or even recede slightly from my
personal point of view crypto was never
going to be a sustainable long-term cash
injection into Esports I could still be
proven wrong I I'm very aware of that
but it doesn't look like I'm going to be
it's unfortunate that this crypto crash
coincided with some other difficult
moments for Esports including the lack
of investor confidence in projections of
years past as well as the general
economic downturn and the reduction in
advertising spending that something like
that can bring and with franchises in
major leagues for sale and even some of
the biggest players pairing back their
involvement in some of their Esports
what lesson should we take from all this
well maybe the lesson is that the
existence of a coveted Advertiser
demographic does not imply the existence
of an easy way to monetize them that's
been one of the really difficult things
after all getting Esports fans to Fork
over for Esports sure maybe you'll pay
the developer for an Esports skin and if
they're lucky the org will even get a
pretty generous cut of that but for
every fan who owns a closet full of
jerseys they're probably 24 of them
who've never spent a cent on Esports and
will never have to and while advertising
can bring in some money Esports is
missing a major Revenue source for
traditional sports leagues which is of
course their share of the broadcast
rights which they sell to a network so
that that Network can air it another
source is having a physical Stadium or
Arena having in-person events where you
sell tickets merch concessions all of
that good stuff but in Esports it
doesn't seem like that will happen in
exactly the same way either and like my
colleague Keith pointed out in his
recent video orgs are now looking at new
ways to build a sustainable presence in
Esports whether those are content
creation new products or new areas of
business we're seeing a bit of an
upheaval just yesterday report from
play.gg stated that heroic was seeking
an urgent cash injection before summer
2023 in order to keep operating it's an
example of the somewhat obvious point
that A team's performance doesn't
automatically lead to revenue and of
course there are still crypto companies
in the space although it's not clear
exactly how long that will be the case
coinbase is maybe the most prominent one
now as they Inked a four-year deal with
Team Liquid about a year and a half ago
they also recently posted about their
plans for the coming year coinbase is
facing scrutiny of its own just like all
crypto companies at this point but
certainly nothing that suggests an FTX
scenario still it's clear that for the
US government in dealing with crypto
this party's over but for Esports
overall I'm optimistic sure things are
rough now but the games themselves are
still incredible and compelling that
hasn't changed even if the way that
Esports Works might have to in the
future
[Music]
I wanted to tell this story I don't know
if I can tell this I think I could tell
the story can I tell this story I don't
know I went to the Apothecary and I was
in there right and uh actually no this
the story is no good I thought the story
is better and then I started like talk
this is actually the I anyway anyways as
I'm not even I can't even have you have
like okay but like I I just okay